1815. Napoleon has been defeated.
During his time as the French emperor, he had redrawn the borders
of the states in Italy to look like this
after the Vienna Settlement they were changed to this mostly to what they had been before
except that the Austrian Empire was given to control to
The Austrians were basically
The most notable of these ideas being that the Italians should see themselves
as a single people and dismiss any foreign intervention.
Naturally, this upset the many
earning them the title "reactionaries." The years following the Vienna
settlement were troubled with unrest
with many liberal thinkers forming secret society, such as
the Carbonari in the South. In 1820 and 1821,
a series of revolts and coups were launched across the Italian state
in order to force through liberal reforms.
In the Kingdom of the two Sicilies, there were two. With those in Naples
calling for the introduction
of a new constitution and those on Sicily demanding independence
for the island.
Basically, no one in these revolutionary movements could agree
on anything. And the Austrian army, soon after, come down and crush them.